estamos en el prado en madrid y estamos
contemplando un velázquez de su primera
época el triunfo de baco la pintura es
intensamente vivida casi más que
fotográfica y va con la joven figura
central y dios del vino se ve hermoso
bañado de luz y está sentado sobre una
barrica de vino y en los cabellos lleva
a hojas de vida y ha bajado a la tierra
para llevar el vino a los hombres y así
aliviar los de los sufrimientos de la
vida y ya lo creo que los alivia todo
mundo la está pasando muy bien entre los
seguidores de baco hay una figura de
rodillas y el dios lo está coronando y
hay un sentimiento de camaradería de
fiesta y diversión bajo parece abstraído
pero la otra figura de la derecha la que
lleva el sombrero podría ser alguien que
hemos visto en una cantina y tiene un
tazón de vino que está a punto de
llevarse a los labios el cual no sé tú
pero yo casi puedo sentirla
cura del líquido es tan transparente
como baila en la superficie y lustrosa
manchando los bordes del tazón
y puedo observar que se anticipa pero
estaba volteando para mirarnos y
entonces no solo la viveza del contraste
de luces y sombras del rostro sino la
manera como nos sonríe con franqueza
entonces estamos ahí listos para
participar y creo que es un poco
incómodo quiero decir es una especie de
personaje de mala muerte con una vida
dura y las figuras que los rodean están
vestidos con pieles y parecen muy pobres
especialmente en contraste con el dios y
la forma de mirarnos de alguna manera
nos está diciendo que somos como él que
nos hemos convertido en pícaros beodos y
estamos en medio de la fiesta
insensibles ya las penas de la vida y
hay una especie de culpabilidad por
asociación creo que es muy cierto
estamos ahogados no solo por la
dimensión de las figuras y la sensación
de proximidad verdad sino casi por
equivalencia moral
y tienen una especie de encantador en
movilidad muy cercana a la fotografía
y todos son presentados de manera muy
barroca ocupando gran parte del primer
plano y llenando una sección amplia de
la pintura y así las figuras ocupan
nuestro espacio y expresan una franqueza
evidente pero también es importante
establecer un contraste pues si bien
hemos descrito que baco tiene un cuerpo
perfecto hermoso y joven tienes también
al sátiro justo detrás de él y esas dos
figuras mitológicas y quizá la tercera
que está en cuclillas en la sombra en
primer plano hacen un contraste con las
figuras de nuestra realidad ubicadas a
la derecha verdad pero creo que es una
de las cosas que la hacen tan vívida tan
maravillosa es la variedad en los
niveles de foco que velázquez se imprime
al cuadro mira el último plano al fondo
no podría estar más inconcluso y la
figura en sombras que mencionamos del
primer plano en la parte inferior
izquierda casi parece incompleta de modo
que
arrastra nuestra mirada justamente a las
figuras centrales verdad
de nuevo hay algo muy interesante
respecto al contraste mencionamos el
contraste entre la franqueza con que nos
mira el hombre del sombrero y la manera
como baco desvía el rostro hacia un lado
así que en cierto sentido nuestro ojo se
dirige al personaje que no queremos ver
y hay un tipo de realismo que ve las que
se inserta en un tema mitológico y que
intencionalmente no representa a la
manera clásica pero nos da unas cuantas
pistas en efecto si miras los tarros las
vasijas que están en la parte inferior
en el centro del cuadro hay una especie
de viveza que puedes sentir de que
literalmente puedes alcanzarlos y
agarrarlos para que nos sirvan vino en
ellos y son puntos de entrada a una
especie de realidad física que nos da
acceso a lo mitológico de una manera en
la que creo no estamos acostumbrados se
parece mucho a la manera como caravaggio
pintaba en italia los temas religiosos
con esa especie de inmediatez realismo y
sentido de lo físico y lo terrenal de
las figuras y que todo está sucediendo
muy cerca de nosotros
en cierta forma caraballo fue quien
inspiró este acercamiento aplicado a un
tema mitológico